see it's now it's on here can you hear
my you're the only guess just had a
problem with this bottle makes me so
much wrong with this it's so big dude
yeah it's really that thing is also I
could cross the head Sahara with this
it's literally what they bring for
entire platoons which it is a lot of
water why a lot of people in California
you got to be ready there's earthquake
stuff and you can get like your
emergency kit carry a week's worth of
water I carry with me that way I can
always find that I can't even wrap my
hands and I just parked at an
underground well like a you know a
multi-level parking structure what if
there's an earthquake in there and then
it's like do and then I'm down there
what am I waiting for the rock to come
get me that's not gonna happen you would
die I got this and a bunch of tuna fish
sandwiches from the gas station you take
- you - I'm good for weeks
you carry - to fit I don't think
different sandwiches in the gas station
is perishable I load up every three
weeks
yes why don't you get things that are on
his parish hold on yes ah it's gonna
bother me stop drinking water my whole
life you've been drinking water it
drives me crazy don't make those noises
either I love being here man I want to
congratulate you and Brendan but
Brendan's not what I want
he's maybe in season I am still a
Canadian citizen and I'm an American
citizen
are you happy with your justin trudeau
yeah yeah yeah he's cool he's a
good-looking guy he's got nice hair
you know he rolls his sleeves up and
stuff yeah it's not really the you know
sort of the I guess criteria for a great
leader though more [ __ ] you're
drinking the water out one corner of
your mouth you see how you're favoring
one side what's quite pleased
I've been dry lately not try I haven't
had to have any water at all not in my
nose I got why are you drinking out of
one side of the mouth junk agenda former
Canadian Prime Minister he had that
Bell's palsy talk above one side all
right this is a joke that there's no
resonance with your audience yeah it
doesn't but there's some fun stuff I ran
with the polar bear and in order to
climate eyes myself
body okay I got a backup okay out now I
I'm sorry that I get a little bit it's
hard for me sometimes to really buy
everything you say and I'm not trying to
be able to it's a colorful conversation
and I'm a polar bear yeah what do you
mean by that
yeah no choose your words wisely lie man
we want to be on your side here yeah and
I like it need as much of the next game
yeah I'm gonna do verse nations okay
fine First Nation but what oh hello let
me handle this
what do you mean by I'm gonna ask you to
stop drinking like that because if
you're doing it to you're trying to
cause the deflection what do you mean by
you ran with the polar bear what do you
think I mean I don't drink yeah take
your sunglasses off no leave a loss
instant I know your eyes would kill with
whatever you bid man you see I was on
the road there what the jug of water
tries me crate always has the jug
allowance watered you drink a day and
why are you sweating
I don't know it's [ __ ] hot out there
I'm wearing two shirts and a hat I'm a
big guy I have a slight salt imbalance
coupled with a possible thyroid problem
what you guys leave me in here I was
talking about your [ __ ] set if you
can call something a set yeah it's in a
you know a room that the fourth kid gets
in a fit big will you finally sick of a
[ __ ]
well well kind of see what I said to
[ __ ] Chris D'Elia
serious man yeah who who's that
listen if you're feeling froggy you got
head and leap all right now you look at
the trouble can you be in disrespect
downing water table here trouble here
okay trouble here I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you're not talking to me
okay
well literally while ordering food you
hey man that's very disrespectful you
know that right don't whistle when you
talk to me let's know man we're not
gonna get into that won't have a nice
time today I'm talking alright stop
whistling right now I will get upset
you will catch things in the face
there's lights and there's pictures and
this my water is large and the table is
heavy [ __ ] that water is so stupid
watch it it's literally the biggest
thing you can use that as a weapon or as
a doorstop or as like okay listen this
is what that you can use that water for
you know on a spaceship when the doors
gonna close because they have to seal it
and because the aliens coming from you
you're gonna be locked in you're gonna
die I could I like and it's hot it's
[ __ ] like it's a steel door yeah I
could put that in front of that steel
door yeah I'd be able to squeeze through
this would be yeah this would be the
stars of the movie like holds the door
open your eyes are kind of dead this
morning well ah that's annoying oh my
god can you not bring an office size
cooler jug of water I want to preach to
them and I want to promise them things
so you want to create a druid Society I
want to create a druid Society and a
cauldron we would have a cauldron what
would be in said cauldron said cauldron
it would be well first we'd start with
bark bark yeah you know we're going to
take the river water the water from the
creek got to be careful with bark cuz
some bar can be very poisonous Canada
lad is John to the point got it
hey I did while everybody's drinking
from the cauldron yeah I'm drinking from
the black cistern okay and that's in the
black cistern ah clam chowder usually
okay I thought I thought maybe some kind
of a like bat blood or something like
that you just got a clamp oh Jesus I
just got a clam is it I understand you
usually you like your clam chowder raw I
do like Rockland one part of the raw
food movement now I know but I just we
get people out in the in the forest yeah
and and that's right we're good new
Jesus Christ will sasso is taking over
for Brendan Schaub today don't just
throw things I'm not ill they often give
this time yes [ __ ] table mate don't
bring I'll get some real furniture
has been on the air since iPods exist do
you know that iPods don't exist anymore
yeah I do
no you don't yeah I do so don't do the
base thing well I'm not doing the bears
thing this is my natural resting voice I
don't know about that I'll tell you
something you um
[ __ ] this doesn't brother that's a
water-cooler sighs yeah Tanner Brian
okay haha everybody knows we it's so
annoying we that I drink a lot of water
what are you here for you
Brian they're here for me they're here
for this hat they're here for the truth
dude you don't need to be me but sure
what's the truth yeah let's hear it it's
not curable hmm of course not are you
just getting drunker and drunker I told
you many times this [ __ ] man
no it's well that's a Manhattan
Manhattan know that manhattan manhattan
clam chowder ah [ __ ] New England clam
chowder nobody gave any clams clams the
creamy [ __ ] you got to get that red
sauce I know do but that's a lot of
clams bro that's delicious clam well you
get a lot of zinc and clams you know you
can eat one [ __ ] clam yeah and you
get all of your nutrition I guess right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]